welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down
[Music]
Loki after that jawdropping ending we
have a lot to talk about and in this
video we're going to be going through it
all it's packed with Easter eggs hidden
details and a lot of things throughout
that make this one of the biggest
episodes in the show's history
throughout this video we're going to be
going through it all but make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss next week
now the first thing we have to talk
about is that amazing ending scene which
completely pulls the rug out from under
your feet in it we see Victor timely
heading to the temporal Loom to finally
fix it and save the TV8 as we learned
throughout the episode though the
radiation's way worse than it was with
Mobius and this instantly wipes timely
out as soon as he runs forward it's a
lot of timely wely wibbly wobbly stuff
and this leads to the timeline then
completely exploding destroys the TVA
ends the episode and you just sat there
like what the hell's going to happen
next well that takes us immediately into
our Theory time theory time for all time
always now there's a number of things
going on here I want to talk about and
directions I think they could be heading
in the show firstly we need to talk
about the way things originally seem
like they were going to go which
involved things centering around the
bootstrap Paradox knowing that a
scientist discovers a book at their
front door that details how a person can
build a time machine they do this and
then travel back and leave themselves
the book and the cycle and continues
that goes on for eternity and I know
I've talked about it a lot before in
other breakdowns but we kind of need to
outline it to talk about what happens
here we've seen what initially appeared
to be the Paradox at play with he who
remains getting Rona to leave himself
the book over time it was thought this
would eventually create himself and it
is still possible that this is the case
now the first thing that's happening
potentially is that this was all a
mistake and Victor timely wasn't
supposed to die here but they left
things too late this now means that
there'll be no he who remains and
someone must still carry the burden of
sitting in his spot the cycle is now
broken and from here on out there's no
set rules for how this is going to go
the Council of kangs will continue their
work and in the end one of them will
probably come out on top it's in Kang's
nature to never have a partner and thus
they'll Whittle themselves down until
there's just one left now they could
also possibly lead us into the story
based on agent of Asgard in which an
older version of Loki ruled over
everything after heading into a white
void a young Loki encountered him and it
was revealed that he was in charge now I
feel like this could possibly be the
case with Loki taking the rooll out from
he who remains when we look at the show
he's also started to see that he was
right and that it's better to be in
control than to let chaos run wild now
the other possibility is that there's
actually two timelines here which itself
would take some inspiration from Doc I
don't want to get too far into spoilers
for that in case you haven't seen it but
if you don't want to know then skip
about a minute ahead go go go now dark
oper rates in a similar manner to how
Loki does with all of the characters
basically living in a Time Loop in the
series we see the protagonists seemingly
breaking the loop at the end but they
then discover this was actually the
midpoint of the loop itself the were
other timelines seemingly branching off
from it but they all looped back around
and still continued as normal the things
where stuff went haywire was actually
all part of the plan and this thing at
the beginning point where things then
sprung from Victor dying here could make
them end up encountering another K and
then that's the one who ends up becoming
he who remains in order for them to meet
him this needs to happen and this is why
Victor from the sacred timeline was
given the book The reason it's sacred is
because this Kang variant has to be the
one who gets the book and thus his death
will lead into the other things
happening in order for he who remains to
be found this timeline needs to be kept
intact which in the end is why he who
remain sees it is sacred this is why he
picked this raona especially and we know
for a fact he's been playing her this
entire time now when Loki and Mobis
arrived we saw that they were in a
branch timeline so maybe he who remains
is still in the sacred one with Victor
then going off into the offshoot where
he ends up dying also forgot to mention
last week but the name timely itself is
another timely Comics which eventually
became Marvel Now the last theory for
this bit yeah last Theory time for now
but this might actually be a 4D level
chess move by he who remains as we know
he will eventually be born again and
he'll end the multiversal war by
destroying every K in order to do this
though he has to wipe them out which
this entire plan that might have been
the goal he who remains could have known
that Victor would have to die and thus
he set things in place to kill one of
his variants I think the man's going
after the council and he could even be
the version We encountered during
Quantum Mania that guy never seen nobody
and potentially he could have went
deeper into the quantum realm the
council talked about how he was in Exile
and potentially this is because he was
turning against them now he who remains
is actually based on a Morse who in the
comics was an older version of K we
learned that he actually played along
with the council to get them all in one
place and this was so he could wipe them
out once in for all so potentially this
move was a masterful one by him to take
out one of his variants and unleash the
timelines in order to kill the rest in
the end the Lum exploding unleashes at
all and now every timeline across the
Multiverse will be free anyway that ends
the time you why me will wobbly stuff
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thought so make sure you drop them in
the comments below now the episode
begins with the Marvel Studios logo
shaking as we travel into one of the
time strands this feels a k of the
opening of Doctor Who with the intro
being similar to what we get here now if
you feel like you recognize this and
it's probably because it popped up at
the start of the season one finale at
Taurus traveling out of a black hole and
into another one which is where the
castle at the end of time was Sat by
itself black holes are something that
have appeared throughout the season with
a book popping up on them during the end
credit Obi also brought them up during
the first episode and Mt did a big
breakdown talking about how the TVA was
inside of one here we get a similar shot
at the beginning of the end of season 1
except this time the Rock is now
crumbling apart timelines have spread
out and whereas initially there was just
the one they've spiraled out of control
and have started to shoot off we can
also hear voices from the radio waves
which too riffs on what we heard in the
final
entry
[Applause]
his if not
love open your
eyes inside we pick up exactly where we
left raavana and Miz minutes last week
with a shot in their position being
exactly the same minutes plays out a
scene from the pair's past and we hear
the conversation from the recording in
episode one R RN
Slayer you are quite a Marvel you are
quite a Marvel
I will be proud to lead with
you I will be proud to lead with you you
made a difference in this war you made a
difference in this
war thank you for being on my team thank
you for being on my team for us for all
time
always for
us for all time
always now ravona is also wearing her
miniman uniform which is something she
had when she picked up Sylvie as we know
she'd go on to be a judge and this
obviously happened after her mind was
wiped now an interesting thing that they
say is the words for us for all time
always that for us bit really sticks out
because the TVA saying is for all time
always he who remains completely removed
the us because he was the only one that
was going to rule as Victor said I don't
do Partners excuse me and he used raona
as a way to get to the top he also
touches upon how she made a difference
in the war showing that she was one of
the keys when it came to winning it
raona Ren Slayer is the love of Kang's
life and potentially the other ones they
didn't have her you made a difference in
this
war thank you for being on my team in
the comic she was killed and then split
off into time where K constantly
encountered resurrected versions of her
still though they were doomed to never
be together and thus she was either
killed or she tried to kill him now miss
minutes pops up and says hey boss fancy
game of chess and as we learned last
week she was originally an AI designed
for this but he who remains gave her
extra programming that allowed her to
grow she has remained his loyalist
servant and we see is he who remains
commands to have the TVA memory erased
this is protocol 42 which might be
annoyed to how 42 is the answer to
everything he says
I'm
sorry showing some regret but him still
doing its aend that he always wanted to
rule alone now from here we cut of the
title and if you've been enjoying our
breakdown so far then please check out
the merch store located below the video
right now we're selling a Loki inspired
t-shirt that you can get now before time
runs out we also have a SOA ons House of
the Dragon let's get naughty Theory time
Ant-Man and a lot more supporting the
channel like this it really means a lot
and huge thank you to everyone that's
bought one so far now from here we go
into the TVA and watch Victor timely
arriving last week Sylvie spared him and
allowed him to go through the time door
which as we know is on the other side of
this now his arrival in front of the
other Kang's heads that's obviously been
chosen for a specific reason due to what
happens at the end of the episode I'm
guessing that we will in fact get
another Kang Varian popping up at some
point in the season when discussing the
series with screen ran the show's
director said I don't know that we've
seen the definitive Kang yeah in terms
of what I would Envision the definitive
Kang to be I think there's still someone
left to come out of the Shadows so down
the line we may be getting more in the
season which the shot composition here
could be alluding to I love how tripped
out Victor is in this moment and it
would be kind of wild if people just
showed up at your house one day and told
you you were the ruler of everything to
then go and see these monuments that
have been built in your name would be
completely mind-blowing and the TVA is
very much a monument for K however this
version is dedicated to the eke keeper
which we see in the next shot just down
the hallway here we have three hourglass
symbols which they carry during many of
their depictions going down to where the
murals are we see B15 approaching him
and this is a big reunion for these two
actors if you followed us back when we
were doing Lovecraft country breakdowns
and you'll remember we talked about them
a lot with both pretty much getting
their big break in that show Victor is
at a point where he doesn't really know
who to trust and we have both sides kind
of pulling him back and forth time is
running out though and the temporal
looms about to go Critical with a TVA
shaking and crumbling around
[Music]
them C to the Chrono Bay and we see
judge gamble arriving who talks about
how to best handle the situation in the
past they would have just pruned all
these excess timelines but now they're
trying to go with a much more gentle
approach gamble was a character that
appeared in the comics and she too was a
clone of Mobius with docs being one as
well because of this they all shared
this kinship which we also see coming
over into the show gamble wants beef 15
to convince docs that the new TVA is the
way to go but whether that's true or not
remains to be seen doc obviously doesn't
think so and in the end we get docks in
a box now from here we could across to
the hot fresh coffee machine that also
pops up during the credits I don't know
about that chocolate soup selection mate
cuz that sounds rank but this becomes an
important place later in the episode I'm
sure these are all alltimely things but
I Googled coffee machines from previous
decades and just got hit with loads of
ads this was all only for new ones even
when I was typing in 1950s coffee
machine so I'll probably be seeing these
everywhere now until the end of time so
thanks a lot guys thanks for getting me
to search that however our editor map
pointed out they're similar to the ones
in Call of Duty zombies which probably
also took inspiration from Real World
machines down in the basement we see
Victor eating Obie for the first time
with a pair both being fans of one
another now I think this shows that we
got one of our theories wrong and that
was that Obie was going to be one of the
show's big bad we thought that he was
the brains behind the operation with K
taking the credit and then shuffling him
away so that he couldn't tell anyone
here it seems like ob's himself is
learning everything from he who remains
who interland everything from oroborus
very much a big head for but both are
fans of each other and it's sort of like
a chicken and egg situation where both
learn from the other who in their past
but the the other person's future it's
like a snake eating its own tail now
this is a little meta joke because an
aaos is a snake that eats its own tail
which represents a ccle of Destruction
and rebirth and oroboros also represents
Infinity which this entire storyline is
of course a part of that's why I think
the ending was meant to happen and it's
part of the cycle that just keeps
everything going now I love how both ask
for the other's autograph and it kind of
shows that maybe he who remains isn't
solely the con man that I said he was
last week bringing them a model of the
Loom they then start to play out the
plan and it's it's kind of like a heist
movie building off that first episode
what I love about this entry is that we
feel like we've seen it all before which
is why the curveball at the end just
changes so much this is given to us by
an explanation of the radiation there's
much much more temporal radiation out
here than there was when you went out
there mobs and also I love how mobia
says it's Loki's turn and that the
little model it it's got his shape man
clearly doesn't want to go after almost
getting spaghettified himself and after
what we see happen with Victor you know
this worry makes sense everything seems
like it's all going to play play out
fine though with Victor finally bringing
out his life's work now Mobius gets
ready to have some key line pie but
Sylvie isn't too happy with how relax
the TVA is when you think about it it's
very messed up how they Mur a Millions
on mass and then sit down and have food
like nothing's happened a key line Pi
further fits the 50s aesthetic of the
TVA and it was even said to be Florida's
most famous treat during the decade now
this back and forth of in action it's
going to get them nowhere whereas sylv's
used to actually putting things in place
I think it's a common on government
bureaucracy and how it's just endless
back and forth thering instead of
getting things done she says to him that
it's just a bad day at the office and
that the reason he hasn't looked at his
own timeline is because it might upset
him that he's one of the ones he's
pruned that couples this moment
brilliantly with an X scene where we see
X5 and the other soldiers sat in the
interrogation cell X5 is desperate to
get back to his life which docks mocks
him by calling him Brad we all know
about your escapades as an actor
Brad he was initially just a number but
because he made something for himself
he's seen as being self-centered and
casting out the greater hole this is Su
organizations like this pray upon and
they want people all just following
orders rather than acting on their own
now it's important to note that the
judges themselves are all giv names
whereas the hunters all get letters and
numbers docs possibly had to earn this
at some point much in the same way raona
will have to as well I actually Wonder
right if he remains calling her that at
the start was actually him christening
her with one but let me know below if
you think what why you think some people
have names and the others don't I'm
guessing that doc earned her name which
shows why she's so willing to hold on to
it whereas xfi would rather go where
he's known as Brad at this point B15
visits and begs them to help but Doc is
too stubborn to do what's best for
herself rather than having things change
she'd rather choose self-destruction
which is kind of tragic when you think
about her character could to Sylvia and
Loki in theorder at and I love how the
signs up here are kind of enforcing the
rules even on the fun stuff one says
bring your own cup and if you forgot it
remember to bring it next time there's
also one saying you can only have one
slice a week and even though it's
infinite they still ration out this food
now the pet talk about how she couldn't
kill Victor with her sparing him because
he looks so scared on the other side of
this he remains wanted it to happen
because he' achieved everything he was
after was kind of like when Thanos
relaxed after carrying out the snap
because everything they' built had come
to its conclusion Loki then talks about
the events of Thor one where we saw as
he banished his brother to Earth he saw
his change of character as a weakness
but now he sees it as being a strength
now it's important to bear in mind that
ly keeps referencing these early Phase 1
movies cuz to him that all that's
happened this Loki escaped after the
battle of New York so he's still very
much early in the MCU timeline he says
that a sparing Victor wasn't a weakness
and instead it's shown that she's grown
Sylvia just sees the TVA as being evil
but Loki explains that it can end up
being better because of people like
mobus and B15 they're currently working
a away to save as many branches as they
can which L's out here also trying to do
he wants to make the TVA something
better but Sylvie says something that
foreshadows the ending what if I was
wrong to spare him it would just be
easier to burn this place down and start
from scratch as we know she ends up
getting her wish which we'll give our
theories on later on the video however
it's clear Loki's arguing that they all
deserve a second chance which he is very
much a symbol for just opposing this
Sylvie never really got one so she's
hesitant to hand them out to other
people I think Loki's still going to try
and fix it though which we'll talk about
in our trailer section of the video
again I'll save that until the end in
case you don't want to know but it kind
of gives us an idea of what's going to
be happening next time annihilating is
easy
hope is hard now Selby says there's a
lot relying on the hope that Victor
doesn't become he who remains this could
make the TVA something good in which all
timelines are open and respected as we
know though the temporal looms destroyed
meaning that everything's now out in the
open which will lead to multiversal war
this is Su that the season was initially
going to be focused on with the creative
team talking about how that was the
initial plan however Marvel told them to
scale it back for this more personal
story about what we have here Selby says
bring him behind the curtain show him
all of this and then just send him home
which is a clear reference to The Wizard
of Oz He who remains was very much the
man behind the curtain leading the TVA
much like how the wizard was doing that
with everything you also lived in an
emerald castle at the end of a path
which could be sort of a metaphor for
how the first season went now Sylvie
asks if they're going to just send him
home but Loki says you can't give people
Free Will and then just walk away SOI
again it shows that Loki is the one
who's really going to be in char
selie doesn't want to be a God but
Loki's clearly accepted that he is
whatever we do we're playing God we are
gods in the end he'll just be playing a
God but he clearly sees himself as being
fit for the role also I still love the
design of the automat with the colors of
green and orange being similar to a
keyline pie now Doc in X5 we see as
raona returns to offer them a deal she
also says I've been gone mere days and
this place is hours away from becoming a
crater in the cosmos making me think the
rock with the castle is indeed where it
was located at one point raona says she
wants to restore stability and in
exchange they'll get a life on the
timeline I wonder though if in the loom
being destroyed that that's what ends up
happening in the end now X5 sides were
there because man's living like a
celebrity getting to hook up with people
like Bridget bordo he turns against
docks whereas she sticks to her
principles but calls him Bradley in the
end showing that she did indeed respect
him they all die though instead of going
with raona which leads to one of the
most badass lines in the entire MCU how
does it feel knowing that all of us here
would rather die and follow you out that
door such a badass final line man look
at look at Miss minute absolute
psychopath now elsewhere we see his
Victor's devices integrated into the
little the little thingy that they stick
in and then he goes after the hot coco
machine I love how he's more interested
than that of all the cool stuff and as
we know he inv Ed a chair with a fridge
in it man just loves temperature control
which yeah I've never really understood
how it works either mate also I think
it's hilarious how Mobius was
downloading explicit games at work which
a you very naughty boy now he could have
be 15 having the opposite reaction in
Miss minute which is when we get a great
Jurassic Park reference uh access Deni
you didn't say the magic word please God
damn it we then see Victor and D90
enjoying the hot sh chocolate which is
when the ladder is taken out by Brad
this is sort of a reversal with what D90
did in episode 4 of season 1 as he's the
one who ended up pruning Mobius at the
midpoint the person who got pruned here
that could have been Mobius because he
might have been the one that showed
Victor the machine so we might have even
had Mobius getting pruned twice in
episode 4 but instead we have a reversal
with it being D90 really lines up nicely
to have things in a similar light and we
get OB discovering Miss minut is taken
over again we sort of see Jurassic Park
reference with them discovering that
she's blocked the computer system which
looks like kind of how they did it in
that film now I love how rather than
having a blood stain they discovered
spilled hot chocolate and it lets them
know that something else is a foot ly
figures out Ren I actually wants a TVA
and we watches Victor gets taken
directly to the war room I love the
thank God and he can tell the guy's just
a slimy con man constantly trying to
play the odds he'd be the perfect
politician because he'll just say
whatever he can to get to the top and it
explains how he got to rule overall
promised to be tortured with a very
small box he decides to make an alliance
as that's what suits him best at this
point the loom starts to overload and we
get close on what happened in the scene
in the first episode personally I was
expecting this to come at the end of the
season but then dropping it here it
leaves some mystery as we guess Loki
pruned himself and this was so his pass
version could continue the path that
would lead him to here I realized this
mainly because syby recognized him so
clearly she had been working with
another version was great watching it
all play out and we got a theory right
at least yet so that one there chalk it
up and all this wasn't for nothing I
think it was pretty clear if you know
how time travel works and the general
way it's used in shows but it was still
nice to get it confirmed here the phone
ringing was carried out by Obie and we
see them in the reactor room which still
his skin written on the side from when
Mobius was there cut over to one of the
Chrono Bays where we catch Loki from
episode one I'm pretty sure that this is
the exact same scene with them even
holding the watch and then stopping at
the loom overloading on the screen
trapped in the elevator by Miss minut
Sylvia ends up twisting the wires to
free herself which also explains why she
had to pry the doors open seeing lokis
see himself also works really well too
and I love how he kind of realizes
what's playing out you could catch a
figure moving behind him in the cardor
in episode one and reveals like this all
I think they're always good in time
travel shows now cut to the control room
which is starting to go haywire and Obi
realizes that he could reboot the system
this would mean that magic could be used
in the TVA and this Loi and salvi can
properly strike back now in doing this
locks Miss minutes out and I actually
think that this completely resets her
she says she's losing her mind and this
might be another 2001 in which Hal says
the same thing Tak can me offline I'm
losing
my
dang
my mind is going now last week we talked
about how M minut had to get a race like
this in order for he who remains to not
bump into her when changing the chess AI
into her lots of time you were look you
get it mate but there weren't two Mis
minutes at the end of time and th the
one here had to die so that he who
remains could discover a younger Vision
in the end she
says you'll never be here which somewhat
foreshadows what comes in the end
spoiler alert there love now turning her
into a crude original clock this looks
like a Dos system when we close in on K
reminding us that there's many out there
as the power cuts out Brad one is the
cardos which is when Loi challenges him
to a rematch being Enchanted he
re-enters and I love how he kind of
makes his mannerisms feminine to show
its syi in
control this is cozy I didn't think I'd
see you again so soon now Rona getting
pruned could be pretty bad but instead I
think this might just send her to the
void I'm sure right sure that alith was
actually Kang's pet dog at one point and
it was told that it had to protect her
now I believe that we'll pick up with
her down here and she'll have to use
help from the other zako prune to make
their way out I'm guessing that the void
looks the same as how it did before
because it's still exists down there as
a bin who knows we might even see the
alternate lokis from last time as most
of them are still stuck down there
richardy Grand even survived Thanos so
maybe that bit at the end of episode
five that that was just another trick
either way though I think we'll see kid
Loki and maybe even the alligator one as
well we could see an alligator on Obie's
desk in episode two and might even get
throg showing up as well originally he
was going to be in a deleted scene in
season 1 and they might have found a way
to work this into the show now Victor
then puts his head in the scanner which
sort of looks like an MRI machine this
lifts the lock down and opens the
shutters up which makes Victor realize
that it has to be him it should be me no
you don't have to do
this but I do this reminded me a lot of
the Hulk during endgame where he said he
was the one buil to carry out the Snap
now what I love about the ending is that
it's built up for so long by the pace
and the emotional speeches that the
characters give Victor talks about how
it's time to be brave and you feel like
it's maning up to him becoming the hero
in the end though he's instantly wiped
out which just completely sucks all the
air out the room everyone's just stunned
and they don't know what to do which
leads to the lum exploding as they all
look unshocked the loom blowing up looks
like a giant wave from a nuke and we see
as the blinding light begins to
Encompass them all that ends the episode
nobody knows what's going to happen next
though you kind of do if you look at the
trailers but first though I want to give
my thoughts on the episode this is also
going to talk about how I feel with the
show in general and I really enjoy this
episode now and the first one but both
of which I think are complete bangers
two and three you know they were pretty
good um but these two entries especially
it just feels like Marvel's knocking it
out the park there's so many Stakes
twists and turns and it's difficult not
to admire how far they're taking it for
a while now I felt like a lot of the MCU
stuff feels very corporate made with
plot lines and characters being
introduced just to make other plot lines
in characters a lot of it felt like it
was made to just make more content but
loky feels like a centralized story
based on a character and the actual
fight of the Multiverse it's really
excelling at what it's trying to do and
for me L is continuing to be the best
MCU show by a hell of a long way also I
I find it weird how every time we've
encountered K the guys ended up dying
and I don't know mate are you selling
him as being the best villain when he
when he's doing stuff like this we'll
see because I'm sure there's other ones
coming and obviously we know down the
line that we get much more powerful ones
either way I won't let it spoil it for
me and I am enjoying it and in case you
don't know yeah just a quick disclaimer
Disney have been sending out episodes
early for review to Chumps like me
however they're now no longer setting
things out Beyond episode 4 so our
videos next time will probably be a lot
later on this is what happened with the
SOA and we got them out by lunchtime UK
time so copyright claims permitting you
know no YouTubers show up at our house
and dox us we should have it out by
lunchtime roughly next week but what's
going to happen next time well if we
look at the trailers there are some
shots at having a p yet and they spell
out where things are going to go if you
don't want to know then please turn off
the video or mute it and CU it helps
with a watch time but either way thank
you for sticking with me up until now
see you chump so in the first trailer we
got some shots of lowy times slipping
that haven't been seen so far this
included him arriving outside a jet ski
shop which I think will be where we find
Mobius at my guess is that Mobius was a
jet ski salesman and this is why he's
obsessed over them ever since we've
known him I think that the Multiverse
will have been blown open and we then
see Loki going to alterate Dimensions
looking for his friends we also had one
where it looked like Casey was in a
prison uniform and Brit over at our
friends the streamers had an interesting
idea she theorized that this could be
Alcatraz and that Casey might be one of
the three prisoners known to have
escaped from there if they were taken
out by the TVA and then assigned into
the ranks that would explain how they
managed to get away I think next week
will basically be lowkey times slipping
into other characters lives so we can
learn about what they did before they
were taken by the TVA now as for raona
we have a shot where she looks like
she's down in the void and she has the
purple glow of a life covering her face
therefore I think we'll also see next
time as she tries to survive in the void
this will no doubt bring her face to
face with the beast but again I feel
like it's going to act more like a pet
her being a soldier in the multiversal
war would mean that she's probably used
to life at some point and it may even
recognize her if she doesn't recognize
it potenti she she could even order it
about and this could be what she uses to
come out on top with I kind of feel like
that'll be what happens next and she'll
be dead set on becoming she who remains
either way I'd love to you your thoughts
so make sure you drop them in the
comment section below please hit the
like as well and if you want to support
the member as a Channel of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one house of
dragon stuff Marvel te's and more you
drop new designs on there all the time
sorry for spamming you with the ads but
yeah definitely keep an eye out for them
as it really helps us out now if you
want something else to watch we've got a
video on screen right now and yeah just
keep an eye just keep watching the
channel and keep watching all the ads
without the way huge thank you for sing
through this my dog's sparking in the
background I've got to go see what he's
up to and uh I'll see you next time you
take care peace